you know when you look at what's
happening in the world now you see that
institutions like MIT Harvard Stanford
Berkeley they are all producing digital
content and sharing it with the world
something that we started with
OpenCourseWare here at MIT in the year
2001 this is now part of the profile of
a top university you do research you
teach your students and you share your
material with the world well what I see
also happening now is that not only do
you share your digital educational
content with the world but you bring it
back on campus and use that digital
content to transform your own
residential classroom this is sort of
the final piece of the loop which I
think MIT is very serious in in
accomplishing we have we produce
something like 200 MOOCs and now they
are all used virtually all of them are
being used for residential education and
so much so that 90% of undergraduate
students take at least one course at MIT
that uses the MOOC open courseware is
used widely by undergraduate students
more so than most people realize there's
not as I don't think I've ever run
across an MIT undergraduate student who
had not heard of OpenCourseWare they use
it sort of like like air they use it to
to see if they want to take a certain
course next semester they use it to
catch up on their own course they use
problem sets from you know several years
ago just to brush up on their own study
of the course that they're taking and
sometimes just to look at a course that
they know they're not going to take
because it's outside of their specialty
but they're just curious about what
what's being taught in that course